my grandmother she was born in a gulag
she was there because her parents who
weren't married or didn't know each
other at the time had been sent there
both losing their other spouses in the
process and they met there
and she was born in in this camp
and what happened once you were released
from the camps was you were not allowed
to live within a very long distance of
the major cities in the U.S society you
essentially became like a third class
Citizen and what happened was most of
the former prisoners of these camps
ended up settling in areas and small
towns nearby
where they lived together with the local
small minorities a local native
population various sort of tribes that
had been living there for for centuries
and
the former guards from the very same
camps
that these prisoners had been in
1953 when Joseph Stalin died
um my grand my grandmother and her
family they were living in a tiny flat
tiny apartment uh across
The Landing there was another apartment
which was a family where the man was one
of the guards in one of the camps Jesus
living across like this and my
grandmother tells the story how that
guy's mother if the kids misbehaved she
would say to them you know when your
parents get sent back to the camp Jesus
you're gonna get kicked out and we're
gonna get your apartment as well
wow now 1953 Joseph Stalin dies
and
my grandmother told me that there was a
Spate of suicides
among these former Gods wow because what
they were doing was finally revealed for
what it was these people truly believed
they truly believed that they they were
beating these people and torturing these
people and killing these people for the
greater good because that's what they
were told
and so what I say to people in the west
always is do not be a useful idiot do
not violate your own moral standards and
your own moral rules for the sake of the
greater good there is no greater good
than your own moral standards
there is no greater good than that
do you know in fact you do because
you've read the book but
most people have no idea how the USSR
got a nuclear bomb
it was given to them
by
Soviet sympathizers in the West
and that is why Joseph Stalin a man who
killed millions of his own people ended
up having a nuclear weapon and was able
therefore to threaten and challenge the
west and that's how you end up with a
cold war
because people in the west some of them
were so enamored with their own vision
of Utopia that they would give the most
destructive weapon in the history of the
world to one of the most evil men in the
20th century because they believed in
this collectivist vision and they were
useful idiots
do not be a useful idea do not violate
your own moral code for anyone for
anything that's what I say to people in
the West
how do you come up with a moral code
well you're going all Jordan Peterson on
me because when he had me on his podcast
we had a three-hour conversation about
God
I listened to it yeah yeah